we've got our a pair of polynomials okay
and we're thinking out how to interact
together and here are the first three
simple ways that we looked at last time
you said we can add subtract and we can
multiply okay so one at a time someone
go down and answer for the first one we
add these two together what do we get
any takers it's many ways 5s okay so
what's that will go to you finish on it
so i got the x squared there um what how
many X terms do I have remember i'm
adding these things together I've got up
to X there and I've got excuse me minus
3x their right to take away three years
negative one right so I'm going to have
minus extras watch after you signs that
it's a bit stinky right we used to
subtract in tears but not so much used
to subtracting entire expressions for
each other so I've done the X's and now
I'll do the constant term hanging off
the end minus five minus one by the six
happy times that's all there is to no
big deal okay again just make sure
you're pairing up the UH the relative
term so you're thinking about those
coefficients and those coefficients and
then off you go for a you can add in any
order but you cannot subtract in any
order so we're doing Pete aqaq which
would be different from q take away p
right so i'm going to go this one take
away this one so again we'll do it in
order how many x squared terms will I
end up with it'll be negative one right
remember i'm going p take away q in fact
it's worth writing i'm actually going to
write this time I didn't do it last time
but this is um this is a tool to help
you pay you take away q I'm just going
to do a straight substitution right so
that's equal to 2x take away five that's
p and i'm going to subtract and a
bracket t are enormously helpful to me
okay because they help me work out what
to do with these signs something like
any double negatives right so I've got
take away x squared minus 3x minus 1
okay so now that I've written it out
i've just done a straight substitution
that's just less to keep in my hair
I can now expand my brand hits the way
out the front doesn't do anything but
here I've got all these double magazine
to a channel four runs so minus x
squared take away negative three x is
plus 3x and they needed one is plus one
okay and now i can go through it
turn-by-turn I make sure that I collect
like terms properly so again like you
told me there's negative one wats of x
squared how many x times will I end up
with wait wait wait wait just I've dealt
with that x squared okay I've dealt with
experts in fact sometimes when this gets
harder I actually did to get another
color and I take off terms as I drove
with them right so that it don't miss
any and so I don't double up on any okay
now look at my age sense I've got to
there and I've got three their cheapest
three is fine so I've dealt with those
guys tick tick and then I'm left with my
constants minus 5 plus 1 which is mine
as well okay so thick to everything is
uh is dealt with okay excuse me as i
said before if you were asked to do Q
take away p it would be just like this
except all the signs would be exact
reverse right you'd get x squared minus
5x plus 4 and you can test it out if you
like all right last one let's do the
multiplication so again i'm going to
just to help myself i'm going to write
the actual substitution down or what is
p of x times q MX p of x times Q of X
and you'll sometimes see it just without
the you know just like when we say you
know 3x what we mean is 3 times X you
sometimes see it without the symbol in
between is two x 15 x squared minus 3x
minus one okay and so just like we did
before I want to do the first term times
each of these guys and then I'll do the
second term times all of these guys so
you can see by my arrows I'm expecting
how many terms in the end I'm going to
expect six some of them should collect
just like just like here collected here
so in the end I won't have six times but
I'm going to start my next line will
six times so let's quickly did it right
I'll do the 2x 1st so 2 x times x
squared 2x cubed 2x x minus 3x minus CX
squared X X expert yeah okay again this
is tricky right this is why it actually
like I still draw the arrows it helps me
make sure I don't muck up any of my
things and also you can see like my
powers here are climbing down just like
these powers of closure okay last one
minus 2x are you happy with that that
look okay okay now we do the negative 5
so now you define x x squared years r 5x
squared negative 5 times when your 3x
plus 15x and lastly negative 5 negative
1 well fine okay good now I'm gonna
simplify this in a second I just tell
you something really quickly which not
everyone does but you may find it
helpful I'm going to collect like terms
in a second right do you see that my
first three it goes three two one the
powers I mean x cubed x squared X the
power of one and then my last three
there you go x squared X to the 1 and X
to the zero so sometimes you'll see
people writing it like this they do that
first three right they do the first
three and open there right there next
three then write it all the way along
their write it like this okay now the
reason why I wonder if you can see why
sometimes people write it like this okay
because you have to collect like terms
ft played like terms this automatically
matches up your like terms together you
don't have to like look back and forth
along the line you can say look there
are all my X Squared's and they're all
of my exes right and then there's only
one execute than one constant term so
you don't need to worry about those guys
yeah yeah three two one Zack poisonous
actually the reason why you're talking
like these powers here three two one
year the reason why they're three and
two and one is because you have 21 and 0
and think about your index laws you're
multiplying 21 and 0 x 1 so each of the
indices should add one okay which is why
each of these in this is exactly one
bigger than each of these okay if you
wanna think about it another way this
guy is X to the zero right 5-5 X to the
0 okay that zero adds 0 2 inch of these
indices which is why those entities
exactly match these ones not a
coincidence at all okay all right now
that i've prepared a lot let's just
simply do it it's 2x cubed is hanging
out by himself on the front minus six
minus five minus eleven minus 2 plus 15
13 and then that fires just hanging up
by himself on you yeah back